جمعيات القرض الحسن التابعه لميليشيا حزب
الله افتتاحها اربعه فروع جديده مخاوفها
من تمدد المنظومه الماليه للمليشيا في
مختلف المناطق اللبنانيه لاسيما وان تلك
المنظومه بكتلتها الماليه الضخمه وعدد
فروعها باتت توازي المصارف العملاقه في
البلاد وانتقد لبنانيون توسع المنظومه على
حساب النظام المصرفي الذي يتداعى بشكل
سريع اذا اقفل نحو 400 فرع تمتلكها مصارف
لبنانيه حول العالم فيما رفع القرض الحسن
عدد افروعه لو 31 كما حضر خبراء واقتصاد
وسياسيون من ان تمدد ما تسمى بجمعيه القرض
الحسن خارج اطارها ياتي على حساب الشركات
اللبنانيه المنهاره كون هذه الجمعيه
المشبوهه التي تحولت لمصرف يوازي بنوكا
كبرى تشتري شركات ماليه لبنانيه مفلسه
ومنهاره لتستولي على مساحات واسعه من هذا
القطاع في البلاد
[موسيقى]